india is being shaken by a wave of new
covert 19
infections like nowhere else right now
the country has recorded the world's
highest daily tally ever
with nearly 315 000 cases in the last 24
hours
this latest wave has overwhelmed the
health care system some hospitals in the
capital delhi have already run out of
the oxygen
needed to keep people alive
families of the sick wait helplessly
outside of the hospital
india is facing an acute oxygen shortage
as covid19 infections skyrocket
22 patients died at a hospital in
maharashtra state
after a leak cut off their oxygen supply
this woman's mother was one of them
she had been here for five days and had
recovered
there was no oxygen she died in agony
she had trouble breathing she died
everyone in the ward died
hospitals in india are flooded with some
warning
they will run out of oxygen within hours
demand for oxygen has gone up
significantly we have at least 350 covet
patients and all of them probably all of
them require
oxygen and because of which the supplies
that are coming in
which are very irregular and uncertain
there is a lot of you know tension in
the system
oxygen supplies are being rushed across
india
after delhi's high court ordered tanks
to be diverted
from factories to hospitals
medicine supplies are also running low
in india's largest city
of mumbai i am feeling really helpless
because being a pharmacist my duty is to
fulfill the demands of the customer when
i'm not able to fulfill the demands
so there's no use of coming to the
pharmacy i'm feeling really helpless
people are crying and asking for
medication and i'm saying no
no no cases of the coronavirus have
surged after millions flocked to
religious festivals in recent weeks
elections and political rallies also
attracted large crowds
giving the virus free reign to rampage
through the population
i'm joined now by dw correspondent
namisha j swail in delhi
namisha we're hearing about this
desperate shortage of oxygen and
hospital beds
how bad is the situation at the moment
well rebecca the situation clearly is
dire there's a desperate scramble
for medical care medical infrastructure
across the country
is under severe stress especially in hot
spots
like new delhi and mumbai once again
today we are seeing people scrambling
crowding around hospitals which are
totally full
trying to get treatment trying to get
oxygen trying to get beds
there are shocking instances of deaths
being reported as hospitals
run out of oxygen and the times are so
desperate that social media in india
is flooded with requests for oxygen for
beds
for medication and this truly indicates
just how
difficult it is for the governments on
every level to cope with this crisis
that people are actually turning to
instagram and twitter
as their last resort yeah certainly an
alarming situation what about the
vaccine
uh rollout is there a chance that
immunizations could improve things soon
well the vaccine rollout in india has
been sluggish india
is lagging behind its original targets
of course because of the massive
population here posting doses
given out every day of between two to
four million does make the vaccine drive
look
look impressive but still it does not
even reach 10
of the population with with at least one
dose
the indian government has now announced
an expansion of the drive to
everybody above the age of 18 from the
1st of may
this is of course been held as an
important step however there are
concerns
that now that manufacturers are allowed
to put vaccines on the open market
this could push our prices and take them
out of the reach of india's poor
what else then are authorities doing to
try and combat this
explosion in infections
well rebecca the authorities are
actually making decisions on a
state-by-state level we still don't have
a declaration on the national level
the prime minister did come out
appealing to people to take precautions
to avoid a national lockdown but
authorities in the hardest hit states
like delhi
and maharashtra have imposed different
versions of lockdowns and shutdowns
saying they need this time to ramp up
healthcare infrastructure
but it does truly look like a day upon
day fire fight
and there might be much more stringent
action needed because these curfews are
not showing an impact
on numbers at least so far mammoth task
ahead or and
dw correspondent namisha j sual in delhi
thanks very much